why
so as we continue on with our
discussions on the civil war tie-ins we
of course pick up with wool rain with
volume three issue number forty-six and
of course in issue number 45 we had
talked about how nitro had been handed
over to the to the name of the
Submariner and the Atlanteans in order
for them to exact their retribution
against him
for the death of Naima Rita but what
name of the Submariner is also done is
given Wolverine the information that he
was looking for he of course tells
Wolverine that damage control
incorporated were the ones that had
given nitro the mutant growth hormone
that was used to allow him to inflict so
much damage in Stamford Connecticut and
Wolverines also informed that the CEO of
the company is a man named walter del
Caen and so what Wolverine does is he
goes to the headquarters of the of
damage control incorporated and asks to
see Walter
now Wolverine is taken to do I guess the
main office of the building but he's not
actually meeting with Walter Delk and in
this instance instead he meets with a
woman named anne-marie Hogue and
anne-marie says that she's the president
of the company and what this means is
that damage control Incorporated or the
subsidiary of damage control
incorporated in which she's in charge of
is the company she has it has control of
but because Walter Dell c'n owns that
company along with a multitude of others
Walter Dell Caen is the CEO and so again
he is the top authority here and Marie
tells Wolverine that he has about five
minutes to explain why it is that he's
here and what Wolverine does is he shows
her the mutant growth hormone that he
had taken from nitro and what wolverine
tells anne-marie is that of course he
had taken this from nitro which is a I
guess a drug of sorts that gives normal
humans abilities and enhances the
abilities of those that already have
them and he says that this was given to
nitro in order for nitro to I guess use
his power to cause a massive amount of
damage and to start the entire situation
that led to the superhuman Registration
Act in the first place but what this
seems interesting here what makes this a
kind of a surprise is that anne-marie
seems as though she didn't know this it
seemed as though she had no idea this
was actually taken place and in fact she
goes as far as to explain to Wolverine
that
recession had hit her company very hard
and so Walter Delk inand his investors
had bought the controlling stake of her
company and so while she is the
president of the company she's more or
less a figurehead here and then all the
power rests in the hands of Walter Dell
c'n and that Walter Dell Kane had
eventually made his way into the
position of CEO but before she's able to
explain too much further we see that
Walter Dell conjoined his both her and
Wolverine and what Walter Dell can tells
her is to stop talking and that
Wolverine needs to get out of here but
again Wolverine refuses to leave
Wolverine doesn't he doesn't go of
course his intention here is to perhaps
maybe exact some kind of revenge on
Walter Dell c'n now what Walter Duncan
tells Wolverine is that shields response
time for a 9-1-1 college three minutes
and that he had called three and a half
minutes ago and so again wolverine talks
about how the the idea here is to
initially leave but it seems as though
he has an ulterior motive here maybe
there's some kind of a plan that he had
that we're not entirely aware of but
what we learn is that wolverine as he
was going through the company i guess
going through the building had installed
some kind of a data transmitter a device
that would allow him to capture various
forms of information and what we learn
as he transitions to forges workshop is
that this data transmitter was designed
to capture information from damage
control incorporated and that the
information that was given to or i guess
that was attained on this data miner
tells us more or less what's been going
on as far as damage control incorporated
involvement with the the civil with the
superhuman Registration Act and what we
learn here is that damage control
incorporated have been given a contract
by the federal government for the
purpose of cleaning up after superheroes
and villains whenever it was engaged in
conflicts but from the time that damage
control incorporated had first been
given their contract they had basically
been instigating a set of situations
whereby superheroes and villains would
engage in confrontation when they
normally wouldn't and so for damage
control incorporated the passage of the
superhuman Registration Act was a gold
mine it meant that they would be the
ones who would be given the contract for
for cleaning up after superheroes they
would be the ones given the contract for
making sure that superheroes are trained
for making sure the superheroes are
prepared
for the role that they will have to
undertake as agents of shield and so
this would be a very lucrative situation
as so what forged more or less tells
Wolverine and what Wolverine tells us is
that this is all about money this is all
about damage control incorporated using
their contract to make as much money as
they possibly can and wolf reins very
angry about this Wolverine is very upset
because what he tells us is that he's
seen this kind of thing before
he seemed that whenever there's any kind
of a conflict there's always going to be
people who are going to try to profit
off of that conflict and this is yet
another instance but again when he tells
Forge what it is that he wants to do
Ford says it this is not as simple as
just going after one man that if Walter
Dell Kim is killed that something's
going to happen whereby another person
will simply just take his place and
Wolverine says he's already thought
about this and he says that just like
anything else just like going after some
kind of artificial program or artificial
entity in the end the only thing you can
do is simply just chop it down to pieces
to the point that it just can't
reconstitute itself and this is when we
see Wolverine going through these
actions going through this plan what
Wolverine initially does here is he goes
to the storage warehouse for a lot of
the equipment that damage control
Incorporated has and he destroys the
equipment what he also does is he
travels to a bank in Grand Cayman and
what he does with this with this Bank as
he effectively forces them to surrender
their I guess assets in terms of what
damage control incorporated as holding
overseas again this may very well be an
instance of damage control Incorporated
using tax shelters in order to avoid
taxation but again the head of the bank
tells tells Wolverine that this is not a
very simple thing that this is that even
if Wolverine is able to take away the
funds that damage control incorporated
it has that those funds are insured and
so in the end it's not going to make any
difference that the money is going to be
given back to damage control
Incorporated and they're going to
continue about their business but what
we see is that once Wolverine is a
successfully able to seize the money
that damage control Incorporated has and
Grand Cayman that he goes after they're
they're like it's West Haven mutual fund
he goes after the insurance company that
is insuring the money that damage
control Incorporated how
set aside now from here we switch back
to the headquarter - damage control
incorporated with with Walter delicate
and Walter del keen is of course talking
to one of his aides and as eight is
saying that again another one of their
assets has been attacked another one of
their assets is liquidating all of the
holdings of damage control incorporated
stock which is in effect driving down
the value of the company which of course
will result in the existing investors
pulling out and most likely the company
resulting and having to go bankrupt but
of course what we see Walter del Caen
doing is organizing a situation
organizing a set of circumstances
whereby they can force whoever this
individual is that there's a sabotage in
their assets into a trap and of course
again at this time they don't know that
it's wool rain now from here what we
learn is that Walter Dell can buy a
mishmash of using I guess public
relations as well as finance more or
less goes public in saying that they
have purchased the building for new
headquarters and this as we learn is
actually a trap that's been set up by
Walter del Caen of course wolve rein
buys into the bait and when he arrives
at the building he's immediately
ambushed by several individuals using
stark tech that are I guess attending to
eliminate Wolverine but what we also
learned with this story is that in
addition to the armor and technology
that they have they also have weapons on
their arms that are composed of
adamantium which is of course as
wolverine explains it to us the only
thing that can cut through adamantium
similar to how a diamond can only cut
another diamond and so is wolverine is
going against these foes one of the
individuals uses the blade on the top of
his hand to begin the process of
severing Wolverines head off which of
course is where this particular comic
comes to an end now from here we pick up
with Wolverine vol 3 issue number 47 and
with issue number 47 of course we pick
off pick up directly where we left off
with issue number 46 which is of course
the conflict between Wolverine and these
henchmen and will reign as he is going
through this seems to have been defeated
it seems as though as these individuals
are telling us that his head is hanging
on by thread and so Wolverine is no
longer a threat to them of course they
begin celebrating and they begin now row
or I guess relishing in the fact that
they have presumably killed Wolverine
when they turn to to the third member of
their team
who had apparently been killed by
Wolverine now of course as they try to
tell him to hang in there as they try to
tell him to keep himself I guess keep
himself alive it appears as though he's
trying to tell them something
initially they can't make out what it is
but once they get close enough to hear
what it is that he's saying someone
behind them pipes up and says that that
this individual that was laying
unconscious was saying watch out behind
you and at this point we learned that a
Wolverine is now joined with a Janus as
well as another one of the Atlanteans
and from here we see of course that
Janus alongside this blond Atlantean are
able to fight with Wolverine in order to
take out these other henchmen in order
to take out these other individuals
now initially Wolverine once he heals
himself jumps back into the fray again
but almost immediately after he jumps
into the conflict we see that the group
is joined by bought by Robert Reynolds
by the century who of course is fighting
on the side of iron man here and the
century tells Wolverine to stand down he
tells wolf rein that he doesn't need to
get in it to engage in any action here
of course Wolverine says that again
he's on a much larger crusade than
anything that is as trivial as revenge
but for the most part Robert Reynolds is
again carrying out the the role of
shield and so Robert Reynolds and
Wolverine get into a hand-to-hand
conflict now this is a very interesting
situation here because what we have is a
being as powerful as Robert Reynolds who
isn't effect able to do almost anything
the Incredible Hulk is able to do who's
going to toe to toe with Wolverine who
can heal from pretty much anything and
so the question becomes what would
happen who would come out on top now of
course as the story continues it has
this comic continues we inevitably see
that Wolverine is I guess taken over by
Robert Reynolds and is defeated and in
the end he's taken captive by shield and
taken to the main shield Helicarrier
where he's confronted by a Maria hill
now Maria Hill tells will rain that
again that he's made a mistake here that
he's fighting on the wrong side that the
right side here is to fight on the side
of iron man and that in the end the idea
here of him going after the going after
Walter Duncan is a stopgap measure that
there's no real effort here there's no
nothing to
we began here that even if Walter Dalton
was killed that damage-control
incorporated would continue to go on and
that she'll to be the ones to make sure
that that happens in addition we also
see her I guess maybe egging on will
rain a little bit I'm almost mocking him
telling him that again there's nowhere
for him to go that the entire situation
here has been set up in such a way to
where he is at the behest of shield but
Wolverine confronts this Wolverine says
that he's going to slice through the
shackles that have been placed on his
arms he's in turn going to take Maria
Hill side arm and that he's going to
escape and Maria Hill says that this is
not going to happen and the reason is
because the collar that he has around
his neck keeps him from being able to
use his powers and Wolverine responds by
telling her that this is the mistake
that everybody makes and we she asked
him what it is
he says the mistake is assuming that his
cause or a superpower at this point
Wolverines claws break loose out of the
out of the shackles and he's able to
escape his bonds and then takes Maria
Hill hostage as well as takes her gun
and so what he does is simply blow a
hole in one of the windows and then jump
out and so from here we of course see
that as Wolverine is making his way to
the bottom that he is landing in New
York City proper at this point we
transitioned back to damage control
incorporated to - anne-marie as well as
Walter delle Caen and it seemed as
though anne-marie is confronting Walter
Delk in and trying to find a way to
force him out to oust him as the CEO of
course she's citing the fact that the
company's hemorrhaging money and that
under the leadership of Walter del can
the company appears to be fairing for
the worse to the point that is almost at
the verge of bankruptcy but of course
Walter del concep down that the only way
that he would step down is is over his
cold dead body which of course we see
Wolverine willing to oblige when he
makes himself known to everybody in the
room now at this point Wolverine and
Walter del can get into this kind of
discussion back and forth where Walter
Duncan says that if Wolverines intention
is to kill him and he better do it
quickly and Wolverine of course says
that he has every reason to kill Walter
Delk in that of course Walter del khun's
actions resulted in in nitro destroying
a large portion of Stanford Connecticut
which of course led to the
implementation or the introduction
the superhuman Registration Act but
before either of them actually engage in
a conflict Walter Dell can consume some
of the mutant growth hormones and gives
himself abilities and with these
abilities he begins engaging in
hand-to-hand combat with with Wolverine
now initially we don't really know what
powers it is that he gets we don't know
exactly what kind of abilities he gains
but it seems that for the most part due
to his ability to go toe-to-toe
physically with Wolverine that he gained
some measure of enhanced strength some
kind of a super strength but again on
the streets of New York City Walter Dell
can and Wolverine begin going against
one another they begin fighting one
another and engaging in hand-to-hand
combat and the fight seems quite brutal
and it seems quite even we of course see
that Wolverine Asuma just pummeling
Walter Dell Kim but Walter Dell Kim is
also getting hits in as well but again
as the conflict continues Wolverine
begins to gain the upper hand and when
he begins to gain the upper hand he has
Walter delicate in a position whereby
he's able to kill him but what we learn
is that wool rain has actually almost
the entire time been talking to to
Miriam who of course is the mother of
one of the children who had been killed
in Stanford Connecticut and the person
who had been on the side or I guess who
had spat in the face of Tony start
earlier in the Civil War event and so we
ultimately see that Wolverine kills
Walter dokkan and when he does he of
course talking again talking to Miriam
says that he doesn't really regret this
one thing that while he regrets a lot of
mistakes that he's made while he regrets
a lot of the things that he's done this
is one thing that he believes he's done
right which of course brings an end to
the Wolverine portion of the Civil War
event with that being said we're gonna
go and bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later